all right you really have to see this
fox news is making another attempt at a
so-called comedy show and
and i say another attempt many of you
may not remember this
because back in 2007 fox news tried
doing a comedy show
at the time to rival jon stewart on the
daily show a sort of like right wing
daily show
and it was called the half hour news
hour it lasted only
17 episodes and it was the least funny
thing that you could imagine
fox news is trying it again host greg
gutfeld has gotten
i guess it's a promotion from a
weekend-only show to a weeknight show on
fox news
fox news has been buying billboards
trying to put this show
kind of in competition with stephen
colbert and jimmy fallon and that type
of thing and the first episode premiered
last night
it is completely humiliating
i looked at a bunch of clips which i'm
going to play for you
i don't know how you could make this
show less funny now greg gutfeld
i've interacted with greg gregg gutfeld
on twitter the last time we talked about
greg gutfeld he tweeted about how he
didn't like the clip
i know he may see this listen greg i'm
sorry
the show's not funny i'm not saying it's
you maybe it's the writers
me this show is what the kids would call
giga
cringe let's look at the first clip even
like the live studio audience sounds not
like
fake but sort of like they don't even
really understand
comedy i i don't even know how to
explain it but let's look at the opening
moments from greg gutfeld's first
[Applause]
episode
[Applause]
all right here we are again a brand new
show and a brand new greg
i'm as giddy as kamala harris explaining
kids in cages
now genuine question is mispronouncing
kamala
as kamala part of the comedy in some way
is that a joke or does gutfeld
still not know how to say the name of
the vice president
i can't tell what's part of the joke and
that
i'm going to get back to that because i
think that may be why right wing satire
doesn't work
then gutfeld goes into joe biden
dementia material
if you love the five and felt the need
for more gg that's awesome
if you ended up here because you thought
your tv was the microwave oven
it's good to see you mr president
your pizza will be warm in two minutes
and hunter
he brought the extra cheese
here he is uh yeah here he is rehashing
the old brian williams story from i
don't even know how many years ago at
this point
i guess would you call this a skit i
don't even know
what this is it's painful to watch
it's cringe-worthy to listen to you all
made a great choice
for proof over at msnbc let's see what
brian williams is up to right now
good evening i'm brian williams and i
am on mars yes i
jumped on a chopper and now i'm on mars
i've been here for a year now
i built a castle here made of mastodon
carcasses
and marshmallows this is where i
invented all the covid vaccines
as well as penicillin the smartphone
and fluffernutter
some things never change meanwhile
what's on cnn
you sir are a racist
racist racist white male
racist
uh that's from the don lemon hour
i mean just painful painful to watch and
again is it bad writing is it bad
delivery
is it that the material just isn't funny
the left has done satire of of uh some
of this stuff you know the brian
williams thing
and it can be funny i don't know
here's another clip gut felt taking on
the major league baseball
controversy so screw you mlb your stupid
exhibition game is about as entertaining
as a match of cornhole on espn at 3 00
a.m in the morning and screw delta and
screw coke
in fact screw all corporations use
stupid execs are cowards and bad golfers
you cheat on your taxes and you cheat on
each other okay so
you get the picture i think there's a
valuable academic study to be done here
is there something about the right
simply being
unable to do comedy like what's the
problem in this show
is it bad writing yeah the writing is
bad like even if you give that same
stuff to jon stewart i don't know that
jon stewart can make it funny the
writing is terrible
is it that greg gutfeld can't deliver
the jokes in a funny way
he's not delivering them in a funny way
so maybe part of the problem is is the
host
but there's an intangible there's like a
je ne sais quoi
that makes right wing comedy and satire
just completely unfunny
i think two problems are the rights
takes on just about every issue are so
dumb
that when they do jokes and satire you
kind of can't tell like
what's the difference between this and
when trump says
under joe biden there will be no heat
air conditioning and you'll have to
flush your toilet 10 to 15 times
it's equally stupid and it either
all might be a joke or it all might be
serious and because you can't tell
it's part of what makes this very
unfunny and then in addition to that
i don't think right wingers understand
satire so then the live audience is sort
of like they're clapping i guess because
they hear people laughing it's
they don't even really seem to get it
and that's part of what made the
half-hour newshour so disastrous 14
years ago
you might remember the first time i was
on with joe rogan
he explained to me that steven crowder
does a comedy show stephen crowder's a
right-wing
personality and uh joe rogan said well
stephen crowder does comedy
and i pretended to have no idea like i
was joking i i know that
in crowder's mind ostensibly the crowder
show is a comedic show
but the point was like how can you even
really tell it's not really funny and
the jokes are not
any different than the positions that
many right wingers actually stake out
so this is just really strange stuff
good luck to greg gutfeld i don't know
how long this one is going to last maybe
you know i think half hour newshour was
a weekly show so 17 epis
i think 17 episodes is like 17 weeks
i believe gutfeld's doing this daily so
17 episodes would only be like three and
a half weeks
the only funny thing about the show is
how bad the show is
and i would say check it out for
yourselves you probably don't need to
um but we'll be monitoring it as we do
um
right wing media and we'll see what
comes of it and we'll see if it's fate
is uh to last more than 17 episodes or
not
we might know uh within the next month a
lot of the shirts you see me wearing on
youtube are actually made by a company
called teddy stratford i love these
shirts and that's why i
asked them to be a sponsor of the show
it really is the most
innovative shirt you can buy because
most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap in
the chest where the buttons are
you don't get that with the teddy
stratford shirts because all of their
shirts come with a patented zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most
importantly just overall it makes the
shirt fit
much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt
is also cut in a way that improves the
look of your upper body physique it has
a really nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout